how to avoid pay your taxes with me a
story of Davenport let's face it taxes
are boring they pay for government
services like the military disaster
relief Social Security Medicare Medicaid
roads bridges transportation and other
tedious stuff you rather have an app for
but like death
you can't avoid them unless of course
you're rich enough like me corporations
and individuals are suspected of hiding
up to 21 trillion dollars in taxable
income I know what you're thinking
how can I get in on the action let me
tell you step one set up a large
corporation with millions if not
billions in revenue preferably in tech
energy or pharmaceuticals step 2 stash
your cash money far far away from home
maybe on a tax-free island the Cayman
Islands is a favorite but there's also
Luxembourg that tiny EU country that you
always forget about which happens to be
Walmart's favorite place to bury
treasure and thanks to a 1986 bill that
lets you put off paying taxes on profits
stashed abroad you can keep more of that
money you made others work for and you
can join the ranks of dedicated offshore
tax haven users who let the rest of the
US pay the seventy billion dollars or so
that they're avoiding are the best
places to store your loot Switzerland
London Ireland Bermuda Singapore Belgium
Hong Kong and Delaware hi I'm your money
in Delaware step 3
offset your guilt for avoiding all these
taxes by donating to charity not only
can you pat yourself on the back but all
the money you donate can be written off
saving you even more money you're such a
benevolent billionaire step 4 avoid
paying a ton of taxes on your salary by
paying yourself a smaller salary and
taking the rest of your income as
dividends dividend income is taxed at a
much lower rate than Sal
income so you get to keep that whole
enchilada which I never eat
step 5 keep avoiding taxes from beyond
the grave
if you hire the right tax nerd to get
your money to your heirs using tailored
trusts you can prevent paying those
pesky estate taxes and inherited money
is entirely exempt from income taxes so
you can pass both your dough and your
tax evasion habits onto Junior
step 6 if all else fails why not set up
a church in the eyes of the IRS even the
First Church of cannabis and it's loan
sacrament marijuana is tax exempt yes
you heard me tax-free weed or you could
create a sports league or some other
nonprofit all of which are tax exempt
and remember Stewart Capone Wesley
Snipes find a good accountant or you'll
be in prison stripes we're young hip and
innovative but financially our
generation is pretty screwed we came of
age in the worst economic crisis since
the Great Depression and you better